la séance est ouverte le compte-rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribuée
n'a pas reçu d'observation il y en
a-t-il en séance
je n'en vois pas le procès-verbal est
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
madame
la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues
c'est que avec une vive émotion que nous
avons appris le décès du journaliste de
l'Agence France Presse
urban soldes
après-midi lors d'un bombardement dans
l'est de l'Ukraine
ce jeune homme de 32 ans
risquait sa vie chaque jour au cœur du
conflit pour nous informer
au nom du Sénat tout entier je présente
nos condoléances
sa famille à ses proches je veux assurer
de notre soutien l'ensemble des
journalistes et techniciens qui exercent
leur métier dans des circonstances
particulièrement difficiles pour nous
informer
c'est aussi avec émotion que nous avons
appris la taille abject perpétré à la
synagogue de la grippe à Djerba en
Tunisie qui a coûté la vie à quatre
personnes pour l'un de nos compatriotes
Benjamin Haddad
là encore je suis certain que nos
pensées vont vers les familles des
victimes et leurs proches
je vous remercie
donc merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs je
souhaite à mon tour au nom du
gouvernement exprimé toute mon émotion
et ma solidarité après le décès hier en
Ukraine du journaliste Harman soldin qui
couvrait le conflit pour l'AFP mes
premières pensées vont à sa famille et à
ses proches elles vont à ses collègues
de l'Agence France Presse elles vont à
tous les journalistes
Harman soldin accomplissé son métier sa
passion sa vocation il est tombé parce
qu'il voulait faire connaître des faits
il est tombé parce qu'il croyait que le
devoir d'informer ne doit reculer devant
rien le journaliste la presse libre sont
essentielles pour nous concitoyens et
pour notre démocratie
alors ici avec vous à mon tour je veux
rendre hommage à Harman solding et je
voudrais également exprimer toute mon
toute mon émotion après l'attentat en
Tunisie et là encore exprimer toute ma
solidarité aux proches des victimes je
vous remercie
merci madame la Première ministre pour
ses propos
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement notre séance
est retransmise en direct sur Public
Sénat sur notre site internet chacun
sera attentif au respect respect des uns
et des autres et respect du temps de
parole je donne la parole à notre
collègue Xavier yakovelli pour le
regroupe du rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à Madame la Ministre
chargée de l'enseignement et de la
formation professionnelle madame
ministre après la réforme de
l'apprentissage le président de la
République a affirmé récemment aux
Français son engagement de transformer
la voie professionnelle actuellement
dans notre pays un tiers des lycéens
sont au lycée professionnel parmi ces
620000 jeunes un tiers n'arrivent pas
jusqu'au bac et pour ceux qui ont le bac
une proportion très importante n'entre
pas dans le marché du travail d'autres
se dirigent en études supérieur mais la
moitié d'entre eux ne décroche pas un
diplôme nous sommes donc face à une
situation qui qui est loin d'être
satisfaisante et parallèlement il y a
des métiers qui ont du mal à recruter et
qui ne trouvent plus de jeunes la
souveraineté industrielle numérique
comme énergétique nécessite aussi de
placer le lycée professionnel au centre
de nos enjeux de formation et de
repenser ainsi le parcours des lycéens
le lycée professionnel doit donc
redevenir un choix pour la plupart des
jeunes à la recherche de métiers
d'avenir et une solution pour les
entreprises qui doivent s'adapter aux
grandes transitions économiques en cours
et à venir
en faisant évoluer l'offre de formation
proposée par les lycées c'est ainsi que
nous redonnerons du sens à la valeur
travail et préparant les compétences de
demain en adéquation bien sûr avec les
aspirations des jeunes de leur temps et
du monde dans lequel ils vivent nos
territoires avec leur spécificité et
leur bassins d'emploi doivent également
être associés au cœur de cette réforme
je pense notamment à la révision de la
carte des formations qui devrait être
qui devrait aller dans ce sens c'est là
aussi une question d'égalité des chances
il est donc temps de faire du lycée
professionnel avant d'être une filière
d'excellence une vraie filière d'avenir
aussi madame la ministre ma question est
les quels sont les intentions du
Gouvernement pardon concernant la
réforme de la carte de formation au vu
des enjeux économiques de demain mais
aussi au vu des spécificités qui
caractérisent nos territoires je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle madame Grandjean
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur yakovelli votre attachement à
ce que le lycée professionnel soit une
voix de choix une voix de réussite pour
tous aussi bien sûr pour les élèves mais
aussi offre des conditions de travail
pour les enseignants et prépare les
compétences du pays et tout le sens de
la réforme du lycée professionnel que le
Président de la République a présenté la
semaine dernière nous allons pour cela
lutter contre le décrochage et
accompagner les fragilités de ses élèves
pour qu'ils réussissent mieux dans leur
parcours scolaire nous allons également
favoriser leur insertion professionnelle
et leur poursuite d'études réussie ainsi
que de valoriser ces filières
stratégiques pour tout le pays c'est un
changement au fond d'image que nous
souhaitons pouvoir réaliser pour la voix
professionnelle elle est à notre portée
si effectivement nous donnons les
conditions de réussite évoquées si ces
jeunes réussissent et si ces filières
ouvrent de vraies perspectives à cette
jeunesse nous allons donc ouvrir de
nouvelles animation monsieur le sénateur
des formations d'avenir avec des
augmentations du nombre de places dans
certaines filières notamment celle
relatives à l'énergie à l'écologie au
numérique mais aussi aux soins qui sont
des filières sur lesquels l'avenir est
ouvert à ces jeunes et puis fermé des
formations dont les taux d'insertion ne
sont pas satisfaisants ni le taux de
poursuite d'études réussites il faut que
nous plaçons le lycée professionnel
comme une filière de réussite une
filière stratégique pour la préparation
des compétences de la nation et chaque
territoire est spécifique bien sûr mais
lorsqu'on regarde les 10 premières les
10 premiers métiers qui sont recherchés
au fond les 7 sont au moins
correspondants dans l'ensemble des
territoires notamment ceux que
j'évoquais tout de suite nous allons
faire un investissement inédit pour
accompagner cette évolution de la carte
des formations nous allons au-delà du
milliards d'euros supplémentaires par an
apporter au lycée professionnel pour
travailler sur la pédagogie nous allons
également investir via France 2030 sur
les plateaux techniques avec les régions
pour améliorer le plateau technique
former des professeurs travailler sur
l'attractivité de ces filières et
organiser une dynamique pour ses lycées
professionnels je vous remercie merci
la parole est à notre collègue David et
souligne pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur nous avons été
choqués que vous ayez laissé se dérouler
une manifestation non loin d'ici en
plein Paris à la veille de la
commémoration de la Libération
du jonglasie en Europe avec des
organisateurs et des participants dont
des proches de Marine Le Pen qui
menaçaient des journalistes des badauds
qui se réclament de l'idéologie nazie et
pétainiste qui appelle à abattre la
République et qui appelle explicitement
à la haine raciste et antisémite nous
avons été en Suisse stupéfait que le
préfet de police que des ministres la
première d'entre elles et puis justifier
se laisser faire comment pouvait-il dire
que cela ne constituait pas un trouble
alors public quand dans le même temps
vous interdisez des manifestations
syndicales au prétexte qu'on y fait du
bruit avec des casseroles
merci monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur une fois n'est pas coutume
de vous remercier d'avoir recadré le
gouvernement finalement jusqu'à votre
première ministre en ordonnant au préfet
hier d'interdire ce type de
manifestation mais comme vous le savez
le guide à la manœuvre de celle-ci c'est
reconstitué en 2012 nous vous demandons
avec d'autres à nouveau une dissolution
du guide et comptez-vous engagé des
poursuites pour reconstitution de ligue
des soute
pour vous répondre la parole
est à Madame Sonia baquet
secrétaire d'État chargé de la
citoyenneté vous avez la parole
nat
OLE me souligne
ça été choqué ça a été dit par la
première ministre par le ministre de
l'intérieur par les images que nous
avons vu de la manifestation de ce
week-end vous avez également entendu les
propos très clairs de Gérald Darmanin
hier le racisme l'antisémitisme n'ont
pas leur place dans la République et
désormais toute manifestation qui porte
ses messages sera interdite
la main du gouvernement de manière
solidaire ne tremble pas quand il s'agit
de combattre l'ultra-droite ce sont
d'ailleurs douze groupuscules dissous en
sacquant en 5 ans qui portait des
messages à caractère raciste antisémites
ou homophobe qui ont été dissous ce sont
plusieurs manifestations du droit droit
qui ont été interdites ces derniers mois
à Lyon à Montpellier à Paris et ce sera
encore dimanche prochain une
manifestation en hommage à Jeanne d'Arc
dans A opéra portée par des groupuscules
d'ultra-droites qui sera interdite par
la par la préfecture de police le
gouvernement continuera sur la question
que vous avez posée en particulier de
combattre de toutes ses forces et par
tous les moyens légaux à sa disposition
les actions à caractère antisémites
racistes porté par l'ultra-droite je
vous remercie
monsieur
vous n'avez pas répondu à ma question
très précise le guide quand il se
reconstitue en 2022 déclaré nous sommes
sur un groupe qui ne cache pas son
racisme ni son antisémitisme c'est eux
qui le disent
vous savez que
est considéré comme la principale menace
en Europe dans les démocraties
occidentales des groupes d'ultra-droites
violents qui se propagent on vous
demande d'agir vite
la parole est à notre collègue et rigole
pour le gros du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
monsieur le ministre l'Assemblée
nationale a voté la semaine dernière
l'ouverture du bouclier tarifaire sur
l'électricité à la très grande majorité
des communes aujourd'hui les tarifs
réglementés de vente d'électricité sont
limitées aux communes qui ont moins de
10 salariés et un budget inférieur à 2
millions d'euros ce vote c'est fait
contre la vie du gouvernement il n'est
certainement pas pertinent d'apporter la
même aide à toutes les communes quel que
soit leur taille et leur situation
financière mais la hausse du coût de
l'énergie fragilise de très nombreuses
collectivités il ne se passe pas une
semaine sans que nous rencontrions des
élus démunies face à des factures
multipliées par deux trois ou quatre
selon intercommunalité de France la
facture d'énergie a au moins doublé pour
les trois quarts des intercommunalités
il y a sans doute une côte mal taillée
qu'il serait bon d'ajuster notamment
pour les collectivités les plus en
difficulté la dotation globale de
finance de fonctionnement est réparti et
reparti à la hausse après des années de
gel ou de baisse ce qui devrait donner
un peu de marge aux élus locaux mais du
fait de dépenses incompressible qui
augmente je parlais de l'inflation de
l'énergie de la hausse du point d'indice
les budgets ont eu bien du mal à être
bouclé cette année cette réalité
hypothèque la capacité des élus à
assurer leur mission de service public à
investir et donc à soutenir l'économie
locale je rappelle que les collectivités
représentent 70% de l'investissement
public
l'enjeu est donc important il est
d'autant plus que pour réduire les
factures d'énergie la vague de
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
publics des gens enclenché doit encore
s'accélérer
mais elle nécessite du temps et de
l'argent aussi parmi les dispositifs
existants qui ont fait leur preuve pour
les publics éligibles en vous
envisagez-vous une extension à certaines
collectivités qui en sont aujourd'hui
exclus je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la transition écologique de
la cohésion des territoires monsieur
Béchu vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur gold vous savez l'attention qui
est la nôtre autour des finances des
collectivités locales et je sais à quel
point ce sujet ici est un sujet de
préoccupation réparti sur tous les bancs
1er janvier de cette année
l'épargne brute de la totalité des
collectivités locales avait progressé de
2,2 milliards d'euros par rapport au 1er
janvier de l'année précédente avec des
disparités entre les blocs de
collectivité plus 2% de progression pour
l'épargne brute des communes plus 12
pour les intercommunalités plus 58 pour
les départements plus suite pour les
régions mais je sais que ces chiffres
bien qu'il soit aggloméré
la suite c'est évidemment le fond vert 2
milliards d'euros qui s'ajoutent aux 2
milliards de soutiens l'investissement
10476 dossiers déposés sur les 1300
premiers lauréats pour vous répondre de
manière précise
600 portes sur des projets de rénovation
énergétique et sur le plan national
c'est presque 4000 dossiers uniquement
sur les questions de rénovation
énergétique auxquels il convient
d'ajouter
2500 dossiers sur la question de la
rénovation de l'éclairage public c'est
dire si votre point d'entrée sur la
volonté des élus de continuer à investir
d'accélérer sur les rénovations
énergétiques et dermiques correspond à
des réalités la première ministre a
annoncé la pérennisation de ce
dispositif je recevrai le 17 mai toutes
les associations d'élus à la fois pour
faire un point sur la territorialisation
de la planification écologique mais
également pour faire un point plus
précis sur les difficultés que vous avez
remontées et ce qui convient de faire
dans la suite de l'année et à l'occasion
des prochains rendez-vous budgétaires
la parole est à notre collègue Monique
de Marco pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
la réforme des lycées professionnels
concerne un tiers des lycéens de notre
pays je dis dernier à Saintes le
président de la République a présenté
les détails de ceux qui souhaitent
mettre en place
allongement de la durée des stages aux
dépens des heures d'enseignement
généraux définition des formations par
partenaire et des entreprises avec
orientation des élèves vers les métiers
en tension cela rejoint les propositions
que vous portez depuis l'automne madame
la ministre
la concertation n'a pas fait évoluer les
grandes lignes à part les annonces de
revalorisation inconditionnelles
destinée à apaiser des enseignants
mobilisés contre vos propositions ou
encore le glissement vers
l'apprentissage avec la rémunération des
élèves entre 50 et 100 euros par semaine
rémunération à la charge de l'État et
non des entreprises
beaucoup craignent aujourd'hui un
rattachement pur et simple de la voie
professionnelle au ministère du Travail
ceci en régression totale vis-à-vis de
la mission émancipatrice du lycée madame
la ministre cantalez-vous assumer les
contradictions et venir débattre devant
le Parlement du contenu de cette réforme
point par point
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge de
l'enseignement d'information
émotionnelle
urgent merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice de Marco je crois
que nous pouvons tous ici nous dire que
nous ne pouvons pas nous satisfaire d'un
statut quo il y a effectivement trop
d'échecs de ces jeunes au lycée
professionnel pour s'insérer dans
l'emploi pour poursuivre des études
réussis ainsi que trop de décrochage
notre objectif est donc clair c'est zéro
décrochage et 100% de taux d'insertion
d'ailleurs le programme
2022 des écologistes soutenaient un
enseignement professionnel au cœur de la
transition écologiste c'est donc une
bonne nouvelle je pense avec cette
réforme nous allons le faire former ces
jeunes aux métiers qui leurouvre des
perspectives aux grandes transitions
celle de l'énergie celle de
l'alimentation des mobilités douces du
numérique formé ces jeunes dans le cadre
d'un investissement massif plus d'un
milliard d'euros par an supplémentaires
sur les lycées professionnels en plus du
maintien des effectifs des professeurs
de lycée professionnel à la rentrée
prochaine en plus de 400 ETP qui
viendront renforcer les équipes CPE
infirmiers et autres personnels
éducatifs en plus des CNRS qui ont été
déployés pour accompagner les projets et
de France de Miss 30 pour investir
notamment dans les plateaux techniques
dès la rentrée 23 plus de 1000 places
dans des nouvelles formations d'avenir
sont ouvertes et dans votre territoire
par exemple des formations
supplémentaires en cybersécurité ou
biologie spécialisée c'est là aussi que
nous souhaitons placer le lycée
professionnel et l'avenir de ces jeunes
alors non madame la sénatrice ce n'est
pas au lycée professionnel d'apporter
finalement une réponse immédiate aux
entreprises nous préparons l'avenir au
travers de cette réforme l'avenir de ces
jeunes l'avenir aussi des compétences du
pays et pour répondre à plus court terme
nous avons d'autres dispositifs le plan
d'investissement dans les compétences le
CPF la VAE les plantes de développement
personnel au fond tous ces dispositifs
qui sont déjà
en vigueur le gouvernement souhaite
faire donc du lycée professionnel une
voix de choix une voix reconnue par tous
une voix qui permet la réussite de ces
jeunes je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre nous sommes vraiment
loin du programme des écologistes vous
proposez d'augmenter la durée des stages
au détriment de l'enseignement généraux
qui est pour nous à croire les
inégalités entre la voie générale les
voies professionnelles valoriser
également les stages en entreprise c'est
nier la force de l'enseignement associé
en formation générale et professionnelle
adapter les formations au bassin
d'emploi c'est renforcer des inégalités
territoriales en rendant les lycées
dépendants du tissu économique local un
autre avis cette réforme mérite une loi
dédiée il y a un vrai débat
parlementaire vous n'y avez pas répondu
je pense que nos lycéens va le mieux que
la voie réglementaire
merci la parole
est à notre collègue Jean-Pierre Grand
pour le groupe Les Indépendants
République et territoires merci monsieur
le président madame la Première ministre
mes chers collègues dans beaucoup de
villes les manifestations du 1er mai ont
dégénéré en violence contre les forces
de l'ordre le mobilier urbain et des
commerces c'est le cas à Montpellier
après avoir connu ces dernières années
pendant deux ans tous les samedis les
exactions des gilets jaunes 140
manifestations en 4 ans des commerçants
rencontrés m'ont informés de leur
découragement de leur peur et de leurs
colères
certains qui ont eu à subir plusieurs
sinistres liés aux manifestations et aux
casseurs ont vu leur contrats
d'assurance résilier des commerçants se
retrouvent avec difficulté des
compagnies d'assurance qui acceptent de
les couvrir mais qui subordonnent un
nouveau contrat à une période probatoire
de 2 ans sans sinistre ces commerçants
n'ont plus qu'un seul choix incroyable
celui de ne pas déclarer le dernier
sinistre lié aux manifestations du 1er
mai s'ils veulent conserver une
couverture pour des risques plus graves
dans la période probatoire imposée je le
rappelle deux ans
je sais combien cette situation
préoccupent la Chambre de commerce de
l'Hérault et son président qui avait
l'ensemble des commerçants demande au
gouvernement de prendre des mesures
législatives ou réglementaires pour
dissocier de toutes les autres clauses
contractuelles les risques liés aux
manifestations et aux casseurs
ces commerçants demandent que soit
garantie le maintien d'une couverture
assurantielle dès lors que leur
responsabilité ne peut être mise en
cause ils sont les victimes de ces
sinistres à répétition ils n'en sont pas
les responsables je ne demande pas que
l'État se substitue aux assurances mais
monsieur le ministre si le gouvernement
ce que nous souhaiterions c'est que le
gouvernement intègre cette situation
vitale pour beaucoup d'entre eux dans le
prochain plan en faveur des commerces de
proximité merci
pour vous répondre la parole des cas au
ministre Jean-Noël Barrault
ministre délégué en charge de la
transition numérique et des
télécommunications c'est le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur grand je vous prie
d'excuser l'absence de l'hiver Grégoire
retenu à 7h avec le ministre du Tourisme
chinois la situation que vous décrivez
pour les commerçants et roletés
malheureusement une situation que les
commerçants de Rennes de Lille de Lyon
comme de Paris pourraient décrire autant
que le gouvernement déplore que les
manifestations entraînent parfois des
dégradations il déplore que ces
difficultés emportent de lourdes
conséquences pour les commerçants
concernant la couverture par les
assurances il faut distinguer le cas des
dommages matériels vitrines par exemple
et le cas des pertes d'exploitation par
exemple quand un commerce est trop
endommagé et que des travaux impliquent
sa fermeture pour les dommages matériels
les assurances sont en première ligne
les conséquences des dégradations étant
prise en charge dans les contrats
multirisques professionnels contractés
par les commerçants
affectés par les manifestations et les
dégradations ces interventions
exceptionnelles s'intègrent aux actions
que le gouvernement mène au quotidien en
soutient des commerçants de proximité
plafonnement de l'indice des loyers
déploiement d'actions cœur de ville et
petites villes de demain entre autres
vous pouvez donc compter sur la
mobilisation permanente du gouvernement
sous l'autorité de la première ministre
et notamment de Bruno Le Maire et
Olivier Grégoire pour soutenir les
commerçants je vous remercie
monsieur grand
vous avez quelques secondes
je vais monsieur le Président les
utiliser pour me faire le porte-parole
de nos concitoyens je le dis avec calme
mais je le dis parce que je le ressens
sur le terrain le peuple ne supporte
plus ces manifestations violentes
aujourd'hui nous remonte de partout sur
le terrain
un sentiment d'exaspération nous sommes
en République beaucoup l'ignorent
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Philippe
Tabarro pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur le ministre je suis
le repas d'un garçon qui va faire sa
rentrée en CE1 en septembre
à l'instar des milliers de famille des
Alpes-Maritimes j'ai été invité à
étudier la proposition de l'Inspection
Académique de faire bénéficier à mon
fils de cours en arabe en turc ou en
portugais dans le cadre des
enseignements internationaux avec les
pays d'y partenaires j'ai cru naïvement
le président de la République en 2020
lors de son discours sur le séparatisme
à Mulhouse qui disait vouloir mettre fin
aux dérives des enseignements de langues
et de culture d'origine cette
proposition de votre ministère transmise
aux familles prouve le contraire
qui valide le choix des enseignants de
leur qualification le contenu des
enseignements pour qu'ils soient
respectueux de nos valeurs républicaines
alors qu'on apprend par la presse que
les contrôles sont encore et toujours
inopérants pourquoi ne pas mettre fin au
risque de dérive communautarisme comme
le pointé déjà nos collègues sénateurs
des 2003 pourquoi tout simplement ne pas
en finir avec les influences étrangères
ces enseignements clivent au lieu de
rassembler et surtout encourage le repli
communautaire monsieur le ministre prend
ton véritablement le bon chemin de
l'intégration en dispensant aux élèves
de primaire l'arabe ou encore le Turc
langue d'un pays avec lequel nous ne
partageons aucune frontière peu de
valeur et dont l'influence en France est
inquiétante alors que le niveau de nos
élèves est en constante diminution ne
serait-il pas préférable de se recentrer
sur l'accès aux fondamentaux et de faire
une seule et véritable priorité la
maîtrise de la langue française
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse monsieur Papin
merci
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Tabarro tout d'abord bonne
rentrée future à votre fils en septembre
prochain en ce20 comme vous le savez
effectivement depuis 2020 et le discours
du président de la République sur le
séparatisme à Mulhouse les enseignements
internationaux de langue étrangères ont
remplacé les enseignements de langue et
de culture d'origine en précisant les
conditions d'exercice et en recadrant
ces enseignements ses enseignements sont
évidemment facultatif à l'école
élémentaire du CE1 au CM2 c'est une
heure et demie en plus des enseignements
obligatoires et il concerne quatre
langues l'arabe le turc le portugais et
l'italien afin d'éviter toute dérive
communautaire ou toute influence
étrangère ce nouveau dispositif a permis
d'instaurer un cadre homogène
sur un accord bilatéral entre les pays
d'imposer que les enseignants est un
niveau minimal de langue française qui
est contrôlée des leur entrée en
fonction à un niveau B2
d'adosser le programme d'enseignement de
la langue dans le cadre européen de
référence pour les langues enfin comme
vous l'indiquez de renforcer les
contrôles puisque dans chaque
département il y a un inspecteur de
l'Éducation nationale qui est missionné
pour le contrôle de ses enseignants de
langue étrangères il ne s'agit donc pas
de promotion particulière de ces langues
mais de leur permettre de les apprendre
dans un cadre qui est celui de l'école
républicaine dans un cadre qui est celui
de l'éducation nationale plutôt que dans
d'autres lieux qui ne seraient pas
nécessairement adéquat et donc cet
enseignement qui concerne environ 70 000
élèves soit à peu près 1% des élèves de
l'école élémentaire
se déroule désormais dans des conditions
acceptables
[Applaudissements]
c'est le Ministre j'habite à 40 km de
l'Italie et on m'a pas proposé l'italien
premièrement et deuxièmement je suis un
farouche partisan de l'école libre
pourtant j'ai toujours été fier de dire
que j'avais fait mon cursus scolaire au
sein de l'école publique et j'avais le
même souhait pour mes enfants mais vous
contribuez fortement malgré des
enseignants méritants à faire de notre
école à lieu de séparatisme de
communautarisme et d'échecs scolaire
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Olivier
Hainaut pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre ma question concerne le service
public postale symbolisé par le timbre
rouge mais aussi par la voiture jaune
chère à Ajac alors aujourd'hui ce sont
des vélos jaunes électriques qui l'ont
remplacé et tant mieux alors il s'agit
pas de nier les évolutions
technologiques Internet les mails le
numérique encore que si on fait un peu
de poésie il y a toujours la place pour
un peu de poésie on a tous une autre
coeur qui vibrait à la réception d'une
lettre d'amour dans notre boîte aux
lettres et puis à la à la lecture de
cette de cette lettre mais ma question
concerne les craintes des mers vis-à-vis
de nouvelles vagues de fermeture de
bureau de Poste dans les communes
rurales mais aussi dans les communes de
moyenne importance puisqu'il s'agit des
communes de moyenne importance alors je
vais pas faire comme Georges Marchais
par rapport à Jean-Pierre elkabba je
voyais je connais les bons auteurs poser
les questions et donner les réponses
mais c'est moins des explications au
moins le pourquoi que nous attendons que
la vision du gouvernement sur le service
public postal je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Hainaut merci pour votre
question et pour votre témoignage qui
sentait bon le vécu
en mars dernier comme comme vous le
savez nous avons signé le sixième
contrat de présence postale territoriale
qui a été négociée entre l'AMF entre la
poste et l'État et qui définit pour la
période à venir 2023 2025 les modalités
d'évolution de la présence postale sur
les territoires ce contrat tient compte
de la période passée des de son
évaluation ainsi que des recommandations
du rapport sénatorial de vos collègues
Patrick chaise Rémy Cardon et pierrelot
avec mes collègues Dominique Faure Bruno
Le Maire et Gabriel Attal nous avons
veillé à ce que 5 priorités s'y
retrouvent d'abord conforter la présence
postale dans un contexte vous l'avez dit
de baisse significative de la
fréquentation des guichets en
accompagnant notamment le déploiement du
dispositif France service sur lequel
veille Stanislas Guerini en bureau de
poste 17000 points de contact sont ainsi
maintenus sur le territoire ensuite
préserver le niveau de financement à
hauteur de 74 millions d'euros
troisièmement l'amélioration de
l'accessibilité horaire des bureaux de
poste qui seront ouverts plus souvent le
samedi et le jour des événements locaux
quatrième point le développement des
usages numériques et de la médiation
sociale à destination des populations
les plus vulnérables et enfin
l'optimisation des règles de gouvernance
et de fonctionnement des commissions
départementales pour une meilleure
utilisation du fond de peréquation
j'ajoute que les actions qui figurent
contrat à bénéficient de manière
prioritaire aux zones rurales aux zones
de montagne au quartier prioritaire de
la politique de la ville et aux
outre-mer et qu'en fin l'état indiqué
son intention de poursuivre son soutien
en complément des abattements fiscaux au
moyen d'une dotation budgétaire dans le
montant sera déterminé dans le cadre des
projets de loi de finances 2024 et 2025
nous aurons donc l'occasion d'en
débattre ici vous le voyez monsieur le
sénateur le gouvernement veille à ce que
la présence postale sur les territoires
restent intacts
monsieur Hainaut merci Monsieur le
Ministre évidemment les propos sont
implacables mais je pense essentiel dans
ce domaine de ne pas pêcher par excès de
rationalité
le service postal dans notre pays est un
symbole de l'État c'est un symbole de
présence territoriale et c'est aussi un
symbole de reconquête territoriale et je
pense essentiel et je vais conclure en
faisant peut-être un mauvais jeu de mots
mais pour nous c'est l'occasion d'une
conviction c'est l'antidote au
déclassement le service public postal et
puis c'est aussi un facteur de
reconquête territoriale je vous remercie
merci
la parole de notre collègue Eric Bocquet
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologiste et merci monsieur
le président madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adressait
à Monsieur ministre des comptes publics
mais je sais qu'il est empêché et que
c'est le Ministre chargé l'industrie
monsieur Lescure qui me répondra le
ministral fut hier dans tous les médias
afin de présenter son plan de lutte
contre la fraude fiscale il a déclaré
vouloir je cite faire payer les impôts
aux ultra-riches et aux multinationales
qui fraudent fichtre voilà un discours
auquel nous n'avions pas été habitué
depuis 2017 vous étiez en effet plutôt
sur le registre de l'Hymne à l'amour
vous annoncez vouloir renforcer le
service d'enquête judiciaire mais dans
le même temps la direction générale des
finances publiques va subir 3000
suppressions d'emplois supplémentaires
d'ici 2027
nous notons avec intérêt l'idée d'une
Coop de la fiscalité et la création d'un
Conseil d'évaluation sans doute une
nouvelle mouture de l'Observatoire
imaginée par votre illustre prédécesseur
en septembre 2018 une instance qui
malheureusement n'a jamais vu le jour je
crains un monsieur le ministre qui est
un angle mort majeur dans votre
dispositif c'est celui des paradis
fiscaux
considérez-vous comme Bruxelles qui
n'existe pas de paradis fiscal au sein
de l'Union européenne souvenez-vous un
peu des révélations du journal Le Monde
en février 2021 dans l'affaire openluxe
nous y apprenions que le Luxembourg
hébergé 55000 sociétés offshore dont
17000 détenus par des compatriotes
français cumulant ensemble 6500
milliards d'euros d'actifs on ne peut
pas à cet instant évoquer la fraude
fiscale sans parler de l'évasion fiscale
allez vous prendre des initiatives au
plan européen sur ce sujet n'y a-t-il
pas lieu de mettre sérieusement à jour
la liste française des paradis fiscaux
qui comprend aujourd'hui des états aussi
fondamentaux sans mépris pour eux que le
Vanuatu n'est pas la hausse et les Fidji
mais aucun État membre de l'Union
européenne Albert Camus disait mal
nommer les choses c'est ajouter aux
malheurs du monde au niveau des mesures
répressives je pense que les potentiels
fraudeurs fiscaux tremblent des froid à
l'idée d'être déchu de leurs droits
civique enfin je n'ai pu m'empêcher de
sourire on imaginant un instant le PDG
d'Amazon monsieur Jeff Bezos un pinceau
à la main en train de repeindre les murs
de la perception d'Armentières dans le
Nord dans le cadre d'une peine de
travaux d'intérêt général
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre déléguée chargé de l'Industrie
Monsieur Roland Lescure
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur avec Bocquet vous l'avez dit
Gabriel Attal est retenu avec Bruno Le
Maire à l'Assemblée nationale pour un
débat de l'orientation des finances
publiques il m'a donc chargé de vous
répondre non pas sur l'aire de l'Hymne à
l'amour je ne talent ni la voix d'Édith
Piaf mais pour commencer par vous
remercier quand même en mon nom mais
surtout en son nom pour le travail que
vous avez fait sur ce sujet depuis
longtemps vous aviez mené une mission
d'information je pense même que c'est
une commission d'enquête au Sénat en
2012 vous avez participé à toutes les
réunions du groupe de travail qu'à
monter Gabriel Attal en ce début d'année
je pense que vous avez été aussi un
membre extrêmement actif de la
commission d'enquête du Sénat qui durant
l'année 2022 a fait les travaux et oui
ces travaux nous ont inspirés notamment
sur ce que vous appelez la COP fiscale
qui va permettre de parfaire les
relations et le travail de coopération
au niveau international pour traquer la
fraude fiscale là où elle est vous le
savez je pense depuis six ans le
gouvernement a fait des choses sur ce
sujet si les multinationales sont
désormais taxées à un niveau minimal
dans le monde c'est grâce au
gouvernement français c'est grâce à la
détermination de son gouvernement de
notre gouvernement qui a porté ce sujet
au niveau international et nous allons
continuer à le faire dans le cadre de
cette Cope fiscale par ailleurs nous
allons vous le savez renforcer les
moyens domestiques pour traquer la
fraude fiscale avec 1500 agents
supplémentaires d'ici la fin du
quinquennat on va avoir aussi des moyens
nouveaux modernes de traquer les flux et
de traquer y compris les flux des
personnes pour s'assurer que celles et
ceux qui ne sont pas en France en tout
cas légalement ne réside pas en France
ou n'y passe pas trop de temps et on va
par ailleurs évidemment vous le savez
aussi travailler sur la symétrie des
relations entre l'administration et les
contribuables quand un contribuable
commet une erreur il paye des intérêts
de retard il est important que
l'administration en face d'eux-mêmes
vis-à-vis de contribuables qui auraient
eux-mêmes souffert d'une erreur vous
voyez nous ne mégotons pas sur les
moyens à la fois domestique à
l'international et nous continuons cette
lutte contre l'optimisation fiscale
voire même la fraude fiscale sur
laquelle nous souhaitons augmenter les
moyens et nous allons le faire merci
merci la parole de notre collègue Marta
de Sidrac
pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre prends bulgaire en février 2020
la loi agecte dans son article 66 donne
les objectifs de collecte que la France
doit atteindre pour le recyclage des
bouteilles en plastique elle indique
également les étapes à suivre pour
pouvoir évaluer ces trajectoire et
surtout elle précise qu'en concertation
avec les parties prenantes notamment les
collectivités le gouvernement peut
définir après la publication du bilan
Adam prévu et attendue en 2023 et après
évaluation des impacts environnementaux
économiques les modalités d'une
éventuelle mise en oeuvre de la concis
tel était le préalable indispensable à
toute décision sur la consigne que l'on
ne soit favorable ou non or sans
attendre les résultats de l'étude de
l'ADEME vous avez lancé votre propre
évaluation des janvier cette méthode
interpelle vous en conviendrez monsieur
le ministre vous enjambez sans égard les
engagements pris et fixés dans la loi
laissant planer le doute sur vos réelles
intentions
les parties prenantes et
particulièrement les élus s'inquiètent
et s'interrogent surtout au regard des
investissements lourds engagés dans leur
territoire en faveur de la transition
écologique ma question monsieur le
ministre franchement quels sont vos
intentions
pour vous répondre
par les communistes de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice de Sidrac je
m'adresse au temps à la sénatrice qui a
la présidente du groupe d'études de
l'économie circulaire et donc à ce titre
je vais vous répondre sur le même
registre que vous m'avez posé la
question la loi anti-gaspillage prévoit
qu'au premier semestre 2023
obligatoirement le gouvernement lance
une concertation cette concertation elle
a été lancée par Bérengère Couillard ma
secrétaire d'État le 30 janvier dernier
c'est une concertation il n'y a aucune
décision prise parce que la réalité
c'est qu'il y a des disparités dans
notre pays qui devraient nous
interpeller
l'objectif de la loi anti-gaspillage
c'est 77% de recyclage des bouteilles en
plastique en 2025 90% en 2029 et c'est
pour les emballages plastiques 50% de
recyclage en 2025
55 en 2029 nous sommes à 60% pour les
bouteilles en plastique pour 77% dans
deux ans et nous sommes seulement à 25%
pour les emballages plastiques pour 50%
dans deux ans mais derrière ces chiffres
il y a d'énormes disparités
la région Île-de-France la région
Provence-Alpes-Côte d'Azur sont aux
alentours de 40% pour les bouteilles en
plastique pour une moyenne de 60 à
l'inverse
Bretagne Pays de la Loire sont à plus de
70% il y a même un département comme la
Haute-Saône qui est déjà au 90 % de
recyclage des bouteilles en plastique
c'est dire si dans ce domaine nous avons
aussi à nous inspirer de ce qui
fonctionne la concertation elle vise à
la fois dans le cadre de groupe de
travail nationaux à se demander ce qu'on
peut faire de plus et de mieux et à
avoir les retours des collectivités
locales qui nous ont fait des premières
propositions 18 avril et pour lesquelles
nous en attendant une deuxième salve le
24 mai dans l'intervalle dans les tous
prochains jours le rapport de l'ADEME
sortira pour venir compléter ce
processus de concertation il n'y a pas
de décision de prise je sais les
investissements fait par les
collectivités locales ce qui nous
importe c'est d'être efficace
aujourd'hui il y a un enjeu de
souveraineté pour avoir un plastique
pour nos filières de recyclage et de
réemploi il y a un enjeu budgétaire pour
les collectivités locales il y a
également un enjeu de justice c'est que
dans le cadre des malus qui sont payés
sur le plan européen pour les kilos de
plastique non recyclables utilisés tout
le monde paye que vous soyez dans une
région qui fait des efforts ou qui n'en
font pas et avec des disparités à
l'échelle des grandes villes qui sont
assez saisissantes quand on les regarde
et qui permettent de mesurer que c'est
pas nécessairement ceux qui parlent
d'écologie qui font le plus de recyclage
madame de Sidrac
monsieur le mini je vous remercie de
nous avoir rappelé tous les chiffres de
la louagec les objectifs bien évidemment
vous-même vous avez dit que nous avons
des régions et des départements qui sont
tout à fait dans la bonne trajectoire ce
sans consigne ce qui les supposer aussi
que nous avons d'autres moyens pour y
parvenir très bien je voudrais aussi
quand même vous rappeler monsieur le
ministre que dans le cadre de la loi GEC
dans le cadre de tout ce que nous
évoquons en ce moment il est un
véritable enjeu environnemental qui
n'est pas suffisamment porté vous avez
évoqué l'enjeu économique mais il y a
aussi un véritable enjeu de pouvoir
achat de pour les Français donc je pense
qu'il faut que nous ayons ces
considérations là et pour ne pas être
trop longue je me félicite monsieur le
ministre que le Sénat est pris la
décision d'avoir une mission
d'information sur la consigne en ce
moment nous menons un grand nombre
d'auditions et nous voyons bien que sur
la consigne nous sommes très loin du
consensus et j'espère que à l'occasion
de votre rencontre avec les associations
des élus vous allez tenir compte des 14
propositions qui vous ont été faites je
vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Franck
Montauger pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues l'inflation s'est
installée durablement à un haut niveau
dans notre société de très nombreux
Français vivent au quotidien une
austérité de fête qui affecte
sensiblement leur pouvoir de vivre alors
que les défis environnementaux et
sociaux sont immenses le rétablissement
des comptes publics ne doit pas se faire
au détriment de l'action publique celle
de l'État comme celle des collectivités
qui sont en première ligne auprès de nos
concitoyens au terme de l'année 2023
l'inflation ce sera traduite par une
perte à Euro constant de plus de 1
milliard d'euros pour la seule DGF
l'inflation est très supérieure à 10%
pour le panier du maire et elle va durer
à ce niveau vous ne pouvez pas laisser
l'action publique locale s'affaiblir
durablement
dans ce contexte les élus constatent que
les filets de sécurité et autres
amortisseurs ont des limites en matière
d'investissement des préfectures
constatent des taux de réalisation
d'appels 60% sur le cycle de mandat et
rendent des crédits
il n'est pas normal que des
collectivités renoncent à l'action pour
cause de capacité d'autofinancement
dégradée par la conjoncture ou de
complexité administrative de gestion des
dossiers par exemple une gestion
différente des dossiers éligibles à la
DETR devait être devrait être proposé
par votre gouvernement pour soutenir les
projets des élus locaux madame la
ministre quelle mesure structurelle et
durable envisagez-vous de prendre pour
préserver voir restaurer les capacités
de fonctionnement et d'investissement de
nos collectivités locales
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre délégué en charge des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité madame Dominique Faure merci
monsieur
[Musique]
le père Monsieur le Sénateur montoger
alors pour la première fois depuis 13
ans et vous le savez bien le
gouvernement a décidé d'une hausse
exceptionnelle de 320 millions d'euros
en loi de finances qui a permis à 90%
des communes de voir leur DGF augmenté
dans la ruralité que vous connaissez
bien monsieur le sénateur c'est 94% de
nos communes dans la DGF a augmenté je
vais vous répondre si vous me le
permettez et donc 80% des communes vont
vu leur DGF augmenter
et assez hausse de DGF s'ajoutent à
l'ensemble des mesures décidées en loi
de finance pour 2023 pour soutenir les
finances des collectivités territoriales
et vous l'avez cité le bouclier
tarifaire l'amortisseur électricité le
filet de sécurité l'amène tient le
maintien des dotations d'investissement
alors plus au niveau la création du fond
vert et la revalorisation des bases de
fiscalité locale à hauteur de 7%. je
rappelle à ce titre que pour 2023 la
somme des mesures prévues pour les
collectivités étaient plus importantes
qu'une simple indexation de la DGF sur
l'inflation 2 milliards 8 en loi de
finances initiale pour 2023 tandis
qu'une indexation sur la DGF n'aurait
conduit à une augmentation que de 1
milliard 100 comme vous l'avez indiqué
en 2023 cet effort significatif montre
la volonté du gouvernement d'apporter un
soutien continu aux communes et
particulièrement à celles confronté à
des difficultés économiques et sociales
l'intégralité des conséquences de
l'inflation doit faire l'objet d'un
effort commun des collectivités
territorial et de l'État en résumé comme
l'indiqué Christophe Béchu précédemment
bien que la situation financière des
collectivités locales afin 2022 soit
encore meilleur qu'à fin 2021 il y a
beaucoup d'hétérogénéité je suis
d'accord dans les situations mais le
nombre de communes en épargne brut
négative baisse diminue très
significativement je suis
personnellement avec l'aide de la DGCL
si si
je vous laisse trois secondes
pardon
écoutez sur votre disposition ainsi qu'à
celle des communes de votre département
monsieur va compléter allez-y
[Applaudissements]
oui je vais pas compléter la réponse
mais simplement dire que je partage pas
du tout l'analyse qui vient de nous être
présentée écoutez madame en vous
écoutant un nombre de collectivités vont
connaître des jours très difficiles et
moi j'ai compris qu'elles sont parties
intégrante du plan d'austérité que vous
êtes en train de mettre en place à
l'inverse nous penchons que pour
répondre aux besoins des Français les
moyens des collectivités doivent être
préservées à tout prix nous restons avec
les élus locaux dans l'attention de
mesures rapidement efficaces merci
la parole est à notre collègue Cédric
Vial pour le groupe les républicains
c'est le Président mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur Papen
DIY ministre de l'éducation nationale et
de la jeunesse
monsieur le ministre 430 000 élèves sont
reconnus en situation de handicap soit
en moyenne un élève par classe
il aide la responsabilité de votre
ministère mais c'est aussi une question
de justice sociale d'humanité et
d'honneur pour notre pays d'accompagner
au mieux ses enfants et adolescents vers
plus d'autonomie et vers la réussite
scolaire
il est vrai que ces dernières années des
moyens importants ont été mis en oeuvre
par l'État pour favoriser leur prise en
charge et leurs accompagnements humains
grâce au recrutement massif d’aesh au
nombre de 135 000 ils sont aujourd'hui
le deuxième métier de l'éducation
nationale
toutefois en l'absence d'une
organisation adaptée et d'une véritable
approche éducative centrée autour des
besoins spécifiques de ses enfants notre
système a atteint ses limites et ne
permet pas de répondre aux attentes des
enfants et des familles concernées et
même parfois l'institution scolaire en
difficulté
dans un récent rapport que j'ai rendu au
nom de la commission de la culture et de
l'éducation du Sénat nous appelons à
franchir une nouvelle étape dans la mise
en oeuvre d'une politique d'inclusion
scolaire efficace
s'appuyant sur une vingtaine de
préconisations nous vous proposons de
mettre en place un cadre culturel rénové
avec une organisation administrative
profondément corrigée en faisant de
l'accessibilité pédagogique la priorité
qu'elle n'aurait jamais dû cesser d'être
en prenant une prise en charge des
élèves plus qualitative et continue en
améliorant les relations avec les
familles en renforçant les liens avec le
secteur médico-social et en respectant
et professionnalisant le beau métier
d'aesh
alors que la Conférence nationale du
handicap a créé plus de déceptions
qu'elle ne suscite d'espoir monsieur le
ministre êtes-vous prêt à travailler sur
la base des propositions du Sénat à la
création d'un véritable service public
de l'inclusion scolaire
pour vous répondre
la parole est communiste de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Cédric Vial je veux
d'abord vous remercier pour votre récent
rapport d'information
dont je partage les constats et une
bonne partie des propositions vous
l'avez dit 430 000 élèves en situation
de handicap scolarisés en milieu
ordinaire plus de 130
000 aesh 3,8 milliards d'euros de budget
annuel pour l'école inclusive ce sont
des chiffres importants mais vous
pointez les difficultés que nous
connaissons qui ont motivé les
propositions que nous a que le Président
de la République a fait lors de la
conférence nationale sur le handicap qui
s'est tenu le 26 avril dernier
proposition très substantielle et nous
aurons d'ailleurs l'occasion d'échanger
ensemble à ce sujet dès la rentrée 2023
tous les enfants scolarisés y compris
deux en milieu
médicaux sociales bénéficieront d'un
identifiant national qui les rattachera
à l'éducation nationale et qui permettra
de suivre leur scolarité pour ce qui
concerne les ESH nous avons à la fois à
progresser sur leur temps de travail
nous avons son du côté du périscolaire
avec les collectivités mais nous
proposons aussi de rapprocher les aesh
de la vie scolaire des assistants
d'éducation de manière à augmenter le
temps de travail à les attacher à un
établissement et à enrichir leur métier
par ailleurs nous proposons également en
amont des notifications MDPH dont vous
connaissez les difficultés que nous
rencontrons à leur sujet de transformer
les piales en structure qui puisse
accueillir et également évaluer les
besoins des élèves nous allons aussi
permettre aux enseignants d'investir
dans l'adaptation pédagogique avec la
formation des équipes avec des
enseignants référents dans les écoles et
avec un investissement de du matériel
pédagogique adapté et puis enfin nous
allons vers une coopération et un
rapprochement entre le médico-social et
l'école bref l'ambition que je porte
avec le gouvernement monsieur le
sénateur sur l'avenir de l'école
inclusive elle est très largement je
crois présentent dans votre rapport et
nous aurons l'occasion encore une fois
d'échanger à ce sujet
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Jocelyne guidez pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la santé et de
la prévention dynamique tout au long de
la crise sanitaire les collectivités ont
demandé à participer plus activement à
la gouvernance des agences régionales de
santé pour mieux coordonner les réponses
institutionnelles sur le terrain
actuellement les ARS sont présidés par
un conseil de surveillance qui se réunit
trimestriellement la loi 3DS romulait le
21 février 2022 a prévu le remplacement
de ce conseil de surveillance par un
conseil d'administration cette mesure
vise à renforcer l'ancrage territorial
de ces établissements publics ainsi que
le rôle des parlementaires afin de
corriger le fonctionnement d'une
administration trop centralisée en tant
que membre du Sénat j'ai été désigné le
22 avril 2022 par le président Gérard
Larcher pour siéger avec voie
consultative au sein du conseil
d'administration de l'ARS Île-de-France
et ma collègue Nadia souloub que
j'associe à ma question l'a été pour la
RS Bourgogne Franche-Comté n'ayant pas
reçu de convocation ainsi que tous mes
collègues sénateurs pour participer aux
réunions de cet instant j'ai découvert à
ma grande surprise que les décrets
d'applications organisant l'évolution de
ce conseil non pas été publiées ce jour
par conséquent la direction des ARS ne
peuvent pas modifier le fonctionnement
actuel pour contribuer au projet qui
répondent aux besoins des territoires
notamment au défi de la désertification
médicale les membres titulaires de ce
futur conseil d'administration attendent
impatiemment la publication de ses
décrets pourriez-vous monsieur le
ministre m'apportait plus de précisions
à ce sujet et m'indiquer votre plan
d'action pour accélérer l'évolution de
ces dispositions
merci
pour vous répondre la parole des
communistes de la santé et de la
prévention monsieur Braun
mais si merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice guidez
associé plus et mieux les élus au
pilotage à la refondation de notre
système de santé vous le savez c'est
l'esprit même des CNR santé qui se sont
déroulés sur tous les territoires qui
continuent à se dérouler aujourd'hui en
associant les élus les citoyens les
professionnels de santé c'est la méthode
c'est l'esprit qui est conduite par ce
gouvernement dialogue et en concertation
sur le terrain je ne peux donc que
souscrire bien sûr voir me réjouir des
dispositions de la loi 3DS qui va nous
permettre de rénover le pilotage de nos
Ars en donnant plus de pas de place aux
élus le nombre des élus va être
multiplié par deux dans ces nouveaux
conseils d'administration des ARS
vous le savez aussi mettre en
application les lois qui sont votées par
ce Parlement est une de mes priorités
en témoigne la mise en application
récemment de la loi qui plafonne
l'intérim médical et qui a été longtemps
attendu
concernant le décret dont vous parlez la
présidente de roche m'a également
interprété interpellé hier sur son
absence de parution que je regrette tout
comme vous mais je peux vous rassurer le
travail se fait en gouvernemental en
intergouvernementale et se poursuit avec
les différentes parties prenantes mon
objectif étant la publication de ce
décret courant l'été je vous remercie
madame guidez qui attendra l'été donc
[Rires]
je me réjouis que Monsieur le Ministre
avez-vous moi je trouve que c'est assez
urbé c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons été désignés depuis maintenant
plus d'un an et on peut toujours pas
iciger donc bientôt il y aura des
sénatoriales je pense que je sais pas si
j'aurai la chance d'y si j'ai un jour
d'ici voilà donc monsieur le monsieur le
ministre dépêchez-vous parce que ça
devient très urgent
le Journal Officiel porte la date du 10
juin 2022 concernant madame guidez et
d'autres collègues voilà la parole est à
notre collègue Vincent Segoin pour le
groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le 15 avril dernier la Caisse
des dépôts est consignations
propriétaires de nombreuses forêts à
suspendu tous ces chantiers jusqu'à
nouvel ordre il en va de même pour la
direction interdépartementale des routes
qui veille à la sûreté routière
Césarée font suite à une décision de
l'Office français de la biodiversité
s'appuyant sur l'article l411 1 du Code
de l'environnement qui interdit toute
destruction d'habitat et qu'il
suspendent tous entiers en forêt ou sur
bosquet les entreprises de travaux
forestiers voilà carnet de commandes
s'annuler cela concerne près de 200 000
chantiers de 6,culture d'entretien et de
récolte ouvert chaque année
les entreprises nous alertent car elles
se retrouvent donc sans activité pendant
une période minimum de 5 mois non défini
et dépendant de l'arbitrage de l'ofb
dorénavant elles seront incapables
d'exploiter les bois en milieu humide de
réaliser en 7 mois les travaux annuels
et de produire le besoin national en
bois
dois-je vous rappeler monsieur le
ministre que les entreprises du bois
contribuent à la protection contre les
incendies comme nous l'avons souhaité
dans les textes sur le risque incendie
voté en avril et en réponse aux
importants incendies de 2022 le bois est
aussi le matériau nécessaire à la
construction et à la lutte contre la
précarité énergétique des logements la
pénurie créera de l'inflation et
contribuera la crise du logement
naissante enfin le bois est une source
d'énergie renouvelable nous permettant
de lutter contre la dépendance aux
énergies fossiles sans exploitation
temporaire les entreprises vont devoir
recourir au chômage partiel à l'arrêt de
l'investissement voir la cessation
d'activités seront-elles les prochaines
victimes
de la désindustrialisation de la France
de plus l'interprétation de l'article du
code de l'environnement par l'OSB qui
voit un danger dans tout le chantier en
forêt me paraît abusive et éloignée de
la volonté du législateur une question
monsieur le ministre que comptez-vous
faire dans un futur immédiat et de façon
durable pour les entreprises du bois qui
comme toutes les autres ne peuvent vivre
sans travailler
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la transition écologique de
la cohésion des territoires
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur c'est quoi je vais pas vous
dire ce que nous allons faire je vais
vous dire ce que nous avons déjà fait
ces inquiétudes elles nous ont été
remontées et vous avez raison de les
pointer on a un enjeu crucial plus large
que la question que vous évoquez sur la
totalité de notre gestion forestière en
France
à la fois parce que ça peut être un axe
de réindustrialisation de soutien à la
décarbonation et de stockage de carbone
cette brique essentielle de la
planification écologique elle a été
précisée sous l'autorité de la première
ministre avec ce plan de plantation d'un
milliard d'arbre mais qui soulève
quelques angles dont il faut qu'on
s'occupe un dont il est pas la question
ici qui concerne les onguliers et un
deuxième que vous soulevez et qui est la
difficulté qui est liée aux injonctions
qui sont liées pour une part à la
Directive Habitat et oiseau endroit
européen avec les déclinaisons
françaises et de l'autre
les questions qui touchent auprès des
obligations locales de débroussaillement
et plus largement des travaux silicols
de récolte d'entretiens ou tout
simplement
d'aménagement 200
000 chantiers sylvicole 15
verbalisations ça c'est le chiffre c'est
exactement le même que l'année dernière
à la même époque il n'y a pas eu la
moindre évolution de réglementation et
il n'y a pas eu d'augmentation de ce
chiffre en revanche cette
incompréhension de vous faites le
porte-parole elle met parvenue j'ai donc
demandé au délégué un terme ministériel
forêt bois de réunir l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés à la fois les ONG et
toutes les entreprises silicone en
liaison étroite avec le ministère de
l'Agriculture qui a la compétence sur la
récolte silicone
les conclusions nous sont parvenues à la
fin du mois d'avril nous avons consulté
les acteurs forestiers c'est tout
dernier jour et les conclusions pour
clarifier les règles leur conviennent
parce qu'on a bien ce double enjeu de
lieu qui sont des sanctuaires de
biodiversité et qui dans le même temps
méritent d'être travaillé par l'homme
concilier les deux c'est le sens de ce
que nous allons rendre public avec
marfeno dans les tous prochains jours
mais qui je le redis a fait l'objet de
cette consultation avec les têtes de
réseau à la fois sylvicole et ONG pour
trouver la voie de compromis qui
permettent de tenir les deux bouts de
cette chaîne absolument indispensable
merci beaucoup pour votre question
monsieur second
la parole
ça notre collègue immobilienne pomirol
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Miss des
solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées
après l'immobilisme de votre
gouvernement lors du quinquennat
précédent il aura fallu attendre un
drame pour que vous saisissiez du sujet
de la petite enfance et des crèches nous
le savons pourtant la situation n'est
pas nouvelle et après les emmener de
sous-investissement et de
déréglementation le constat dressé
aujourd'hui par le rapport de
l'Inspection générale des affaires
sociales est sans appel ainsi les gaz
souligne que sur le plan systémique les
conditions ne sont pas réunies à ce jour
pour garantir une qualité d'accueil dans
les crèches le rapport pointe ainsi du
doigt à la fois la maltraitance
institutionnelle qui pèse sur les
professionnels un taux d'encadrement
trop faible une formation insuffisante
des professionnels des modes de
financement inadéquat une gouvernance
incontrol qui doivent être renforcés et
il va plus loin en faisant le parallèle
avec la situation des EHPAD en effet le
rapport note que le secteur des crèches
également marqué par une domination de
grand groupe privé abusent lucratif ce
qui a conduit ces dernières années à et
je le cite encore une dégradation
progressive de la qualité d'accueil au
profit d'une logique financière Après
les hôpitaux les EHPAD c'est au tour des
crèches subir le délaissement de la part
de la puissance publique et ce au profit
de la logique marchande alors Monsieur
le Ministre quand allez-vous enfin
réformer et investir dans le secteur de
la petite enfance pour permettre à
chaque enfant d'être accueilli dans des
conditions qui garantissent son
développement et son bien-être pour vous
répondre la parole est communiste et
solidarités de l'autonomie les personnes
handicapées monsieur Combes merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Poumirol
vous avez raison la sécurité des enfants
accueillis doit être notre priorité
collective la première de nos priorités
collectives et c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle dès que j'ai été
nommée ministre en juillet dernier j'ai
diligenté une mission de l'Inspection
générale des affaires sociales pour
faire la lumière sur la situation dans
les crèches nous assurer que de la
robustesse des règles appliquées dans
ces dans ces crèches nous assurer de la
qualité aussi des contrôles et puis j'ai
demandé à ce que les inspecteurs nous
fassent un certain nombre de
propositions les constats vous les avez
vous les avez dit mais un constat me
semble-t-il et important de noter c'est
que la question de l'hétérogénéité de la
qualité de l'accueil se retrouve dans
tous les secteurs publics associatifs et
privé commercial et donc n'est pas
l'apanage d'un seul de ces de ces
secteurs beaucoup est dû à la pénurie de
professionnels dans dans ces crèches
beaucoup est dû aussi
au manque d'intégration des
connaissances sur le jeune enfant dans
les projets d'établissement et dans la
formation des professionnels vous l'avez
dit et puis dans les limites des
contrôles qui sont portés aujourd'hui
par les services de PMI des départements
vous le savez j'ai fait de la lutte
contre les maltraitances une priorité de
mon mandat j'ai lancé récemment les
états généraux de la lutte contre les
maltraitances c'est un fil rouge sur
l'ensemble de du portefeuille dont j'ai
la responsabilité de pouvoir lutter
contre ces maltraitances je précise
également par ailleurs que la qualité et
la sécurité d'accueil étant notre
première des prix notre première
priorité les questions de laisser ouvert
des crèches ou des places d'accueil en
cas de manque de professionnels nous
avons demandé la première ministre la
demander l'été dernier à l'ensemble des
préfets de pouvoir faire mes des crèches
en cas de manque de professionnels dans
ces crèches j'aurai également à coeur de
mettre en oeuvre les 39 propositions qui
ont été faites par les inspecteurs
généraux des affaires sociales dans le
cas de la mise en place de la garantie
d'accueil du jeune enfant
madame
monsieur le ministre vous venez de
parler des 39 propositions formulées
dans le ce rapport de Ligas c'est certes
vrai quand vous dites qu'il a de l'été
de l'hétérogénéité pardon dans les dans
le service public ou dans les services
privés n'oubliez pas que les normes en
qualité de personnel ne sont pas les
mêmes dans les crèches privées que dans
les chèvres crèches publiques les normes
ne sont pas les mêmes et vous savez bien
que le personnel et la dépense
essentielle dans le fonctionnement d'une
crèche nous avons besoin d'acte monsieur
le ministre pas d'intention vague et son
calendrier il est temps de mettre en
place un véritable service public de la
petite enfance
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue
Christophe André François pour le groupe
des Républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
Affaires étrangères la ministre il y a
deux ans jour pour jour le 10 mai 2021
notre compatriote Juan Rémy quinolo a
été arrêté à Bangui par les autorités
centrafricaines pour de prétendus
atteintes à la sécurité intérieure de
l'État complot et espionnage notre
compatriote a été maintenue dans un
premier temps en détention provisoire ce
qui a légitimement provoqué des tensions
entre la France et la Centrafrique
désormais en liberté provisoire et sous
le coup d'une enquête judiciaire qui
s'éternise et pour dubuesque fait
d'espionnage notre compatriote est
hébergé par l'ambassadeur de France dont
je tiens ici à souligner et à saluer
l'implication dans l'aide et le soutien
qui lui apporte
a entamé une greffe de la faim pour
dénoncer sa situation les allégations
fantaisistes portées contre notre
compatriote ne peuvent en aucun cas
constituer le fondement d'une enquête
judiciaire sérieuse et même si la France
appelle à sa libération immédiate la
situation hélas n'évolue pas la
situation de notre compatriotes relève à
bien des égards du groupe de travail de
l'Organisation des Nations Unies sur la
détention arbitraire il est désormais
l'otage de Bangui dans une relation
délétère entre la France et la
Centrafrique rien de plus nous ne
pouvons pas l'accepter ce triste
anniversaire doit être le dernier et la
France doit tout mettre en œuvre pour
que Ron Rémy quinolo retrouve sa liberté
et son pays
pour vous répondre la parole est top
ministre délégué en charge notamment des
Français de l'étranger monsieur le
ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur fera ça je vous
remercie de votre question et voici ce
que je peux vous répondre à ce stade
avec toutes les précautions qui
conviennent dans cette situation et
j'espère que vous le comprendrez vous
l'avez dit effectivement monsieur rémi
quignolo a été arrêté qui a Bangui le
mais 2021 il a été incarcéré en
République centrafricaine et dans le cas
d'une détention provisoire a été détenue
plus de 16 mois
la justice centrafricaine a décidé le 28
septembre 2022 de sa mise en liberté
provisoire afin qu'il puisse recevoir
les soins médicaux nécessaires dans
l'attente de son procès
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
durant sa détention provisoire ce
quignolo a bénéficié de ce qu'on appelle
la protection consulaire prévue par la
convention de Vienne du 23 avril
1963 et il a reçu à ce titre un certain
nombre de visites consulaires cette
situation continue d'être suivie
quotidiennement à la fois à Bangui et à
Paris et les services du Quai d'Orsay
sont en relation étroite avec la famille
ils suivent la situation et nous
espérons évidemment une résolution
rapide de cette situation merci
Monsieur François
merci votre réponse monsieur ministre
moi ce que je veux juste c'est que
Monsieur quinolo sa famille sache que
loin de Bangui il y a des gens qui
s'occupent de lui se préoccupe de lui et
mettre tout en œuvre pour qu'il revienne
vers les siens le plus rapidement
possible merci merci
la parole est à notre collègue Hugues
souris pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre depuis de nombreuses années
pour les fêtes de Pentecôte à neuvois
dans le Loiret des milliers de pèlerins
issus de la communauté des gens du
voyage provenant de la France entière
convergent terrain privé de
l'association Vie et Lumière en 2022 ils
étaient plus de 30 000 et depuis le 6
mai dernier ils sont plus de 40 000
voyageurs dans une commune de 1200
habitants au sein d'un bassin de vie de
25000 personnes autour de la petite
ville de Gien faute de place des gens du
voyage
occupent illégalement des terrains
agricoles branchent leurs installations
électriques et d'eau directement chez
des particuliers et les alentours
devenant un véritable cloaque son jaugés
d'immondis dans tout genre de fortes
tensions sont en train d'éclater entre
les habitants excéder et des gens des
voyages cette situation pose de graves
problèmes de sécurité de salubrité et de
santé publique d'autant que les urgences
de Gien sont fermées jusqu'au mois de
septembre prochain faute de personnel
aucun des services publics les
dimensionné pour un tel à jusqu'à
maintenant les utiles acceptaient le
principe d'un unique rassemblement dès
lors que celui-ci respectait les
capacités du terrain soient 20000
personnes ce n'est plus le cas et depuis
quelques années un deuxième
rassemblement de niveau européen est
organisé en août en 2015 les élus locaux
et les parlementaires dont nos collègues
sueurs et Cardou avait déjà alerté le
Premier ministre lequel c'était engagé à
ce que l'État propose dorénavant un
autre lieu pour un deuxième
rassemblement annuel la promesse fut
respectée pendant quelques années mais
elle ne Quintin depuis les élus ont été
promenés dans les différents ministères
et ont été reçus par plusieurs premiers
ministres enfin l'ensemble des habitants
en subissent au quotidien nuisant et
incivilités et la commune de nevoye
demeure isolées mesdames la ministre
pouvez-vous premièrement faire respecter
la parole de l'État et deuxièmement
comptez-vous faire preuve d'autorité
pour enfin reprendre le contrôle de
cette situation inadmissible
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la ministre des collectivités
territoriales madame Faure
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur sorry j'entends et j'ai bien
conscience des difficultés de la
problématique que vous soulevez le
rassemblement de nos voix et je le sais
pour avoir échangé avec Anthony Dubois
revêt une importance toute particulière
pour les gens du voyage se rassemblement
évangélique qui se déroule à nevoi du 6
au 14 mai devrait accueillir environ 20
000 personnes il se réunit aujourd'hui
avec plus de 40 000 personnes comme vous
l'avez indiquées dans une commune de
1200 habitants et fait peser sur cette
commune et les services de l'État une
très forte contrainte je tenais à saluer
l'implication des élus et des services
de l'État pour que cet événement se
déroule dans les meilleures conditions
cette surfécation pose de réels
problèmes en termes d'installation des
gens du voyage sur des terrains non
prévus à cet effet en termes de
circulation en termes sanitaire sur ces
aspects la préfète du Loiret le
gouvernement ont pris des mesures fortes
dans l'optique d'un second rassemblement
au mois d'août j'entends les inquiétudes
dériverains et des élus et le
gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé sur
ce sujet je m'engage à ce que pour le
départ propre élu association d'élus
associations Vie et Lumière soit
associée pour dégager des solutions
pérennes pour les années à venir dans le
respect des sensibilités de chacun je
vous remercie monsieur sorry j'aime la
ministre je constate que vous n'apportez
aucune solution concrète pour le
deuxième rassemblement le gouvernement
le gouvernement fuit ses responsabilités
abandonnent et livre à eux-mêmes les
habitants de nevoye ainsi vous actez la
totale d'émission de l'État pour
protéger ses citoyens
[Applaudissements]
merci mon cher collègue
les prochaines questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement auront lieu mercredi 17 mai
merci madame la Première ministre madame
monsieur les ministres je vais suspendre
la séance sera reprise à 16h30 pour
l'attribution des prérogatives d'une
commission d'enquête à la commission des
finances et pour les explications de
vote puis le vote sur le projet de loi
ratifiant les ordonnances relatives à la
partie législative du livre 7 du code
monétaire et financier et portant
diverses dispositions relatives à
l'Outre-mer la séance est suspendue